Hello, this is Dr. Cameron Connors and I'm here to answer some questions that most people have first question here is
How is Connors clinic different? How are we different than other clinics? What makes us unique as a clinic?
Well, let's go over some of the things because I don't want people to have wrong
expectations before anybody starts with us
I want them to understand
What we're all about and the role that we can play in your health care
And not have a misunderstanding there. So the first thing is that we are
using nutrition diet emotional and spiritual support and frequencies to help your body heal as best it can
We are not the healers
We are not God. We are doing the work
So if you heal from late-stage
Four cancer and you do great don't give us credit. Give God the credit at your body the credit for doing what it can our
approach is
truly
To help build up your immune system build up your body to be able to fight the disease that you're dealing with
That's really our approach. We don't treat the cancer
So I don't just say that from a medical legal standpoint. We really don't we're not treating the cancer
We're stimulating your body to be able to fight this back
That's why we're not dogmatically opposed to chemotherapy or radiation or surgery that can help to bulk the cancer and help things
Then if you do choose to go that road that we need to support your body and your cells through that
It's all about building up the blue the
Area where the cancer was the body that is ill that has allowed the cancer to grow
Build that back. So your body won't allow it to grow again
So understand our peace in that so don't have wrong expectations that you're gonna just
Join our program and you're gonna get the right for you're gonna get nutrition and
Magically everything's gonna disappear. That's a very wrong
Expectation we never want to lead anybody out if that's gonna happen because it just might not happen
We'd have to know that God is in control in all things and our approach is just to build up your body
Your God given immune system so that it can do its best and
Whether it does its best and it has victory over this disease or not
That's between your immune system in this cancer and God and you and that needs to be worked out and we'll help you work that out
But we can only do so much you have to have a right expectation
Coming here
Secondly, you might be used to more
Dictoral medicine and by that I mean you might be used to going to a doctor and them kind of
Taking the responsibility of the disease away from you like this is what you have
This is what we're gonna do. We're gonna start a pick line on Tuesday
And we're gonna get you on chemo next Monday
And you're gonna be doing it every three weeks
Baba Baba and you really don't have a choice and some people honestly like that
Now you're listening to this video because maybe you kind of had some pushback about that
But the truth is the vast majority of people would rather have somebody else take their responsibility of their disease away from them
Because they're the experts and put it in the hands of these experts to now make it disappear
Well, that doesn't disappear. There's a little dismay there
The truth is that's not how we practice. So if you're coming here thinking that we're gonna just be
Dude, this this and this and then magically your cancer is gonna go away
You don't start with us. You're making a mistake. We're not that kind of practice
We believe in the sovereignty of God
We believe to stay in our role in the responsibility that he's given us and that is is give you the best
Recommendations this is what we believe through prayer we pray for every cheek swab that we test
for through prayer
This is what we believe that God is telling us that you should do and
Then you have that responsibility to pray and let's make sure that that's what is right for you
So we're not dictating your care in any way. So
Understand that or not here to just tell you what to do we're here to lead you and give you choices. So
That is what we feel our responsibility is and I understand we have some patients that kind of get upset at us because
Why can't you just tell me what to do?
Because I can't
What what doctors do just tell you what to do
This is what we're gonna do to get you better quite honestly. It's a lie. How do they know?
They don't know so they can give their best recommendation. They can give their opinion
But that's what it is so we don't call it anything other than that
So we're giving you our best recommendation our opinion and and
Guiding you and coaching you we're coming along you side you as a friend to try to lead you in the right way
But we're not gonna dictate your care
thirdly
We believe that care needs to be valuable. It needs to be changeable because your body is changing
Protocols must be adapted as cancer cells morph because they do and your body chemistry changes your body chemistry
Changes if you decide to do chemo your body chemistry changes just over time with dietary changes
The blue of your body is constantly
Mobile and changing and adapting to its environment. Well, we need to be
Looking at your protocol differently on a regular basis as well
Even if you're doing great, it's still good to get another cheek swab people think that oh
We're gonna do this cheek swab and the genetic test and we're gonna get the protocol and everything's gonna be okay
Well, I'm sorry, but it just doesn't work that way your body is constantly changing and the fact that your body's constantly changing means
We have to constantly stay on top of it
That's why in year three or in your binder that we give you with your rife
You get three more cheek swabs so that you can send those in to get checked and we can order more cheek swabs
Because you need to be checked on a regular basis as the cancer changes tries to grow again
If everything we're doing is just not put the brakes on it
We need to tweak things change things add things
That's our promise to you we cannot promise that you're gonna get better
We can't promise a success rate. We can't promise that if we try and do everything that it's gonna work
Because it's out of our hands
It's really in the hands of God and that was really preordained before the foundations of the earth were set
But our promise is to do everything on our side that we can possibly do
But don't think your initial protocol is your final protocol because it's almost never is
So we need to be
able to change and to more for to do things and that leads us to the fourth point
We are available
So you need to reach out to us if you're hurting emotionally if you're hurting physically
If things are going the wrong direction
We're here to talk we're here for the ideas to bounce off of each other
We're here to retest as I said we're here to tweak your program
And mostly we're here to pray and pray for you and pray with you
So understand that's a piece that makes us different. We stay in our lane
We don't take responsibility for your disease. We don't treat the disease. We're treating you that treatment plan has to be
changeable and moldable and tweakable and then ultimately we believe that we serve
Sovereign God and
Understanding the God's sovereignty and all things we're here to bring him glory
So that's what we're trying to do. We're trying to instill that in you
Also that you could have peace in your most difficult circumstances
If you're trusting him in all things and knowing that you he you aren't literally in his hands
even in this and
Sometimes it's difficult to feel that and difficult to understand that and that's where we're here to come alongside you
And encourage you in that way too
Thank you